you and I became friends on the trail
did you spend any time with President
Biden when he was candidate Biden on the
trail I wouldn't say I spent time with
him I met him a few times he was he was
lovely he was perfectly polite kind
respectful his wife I think is
particularly Charming I met some of his
family I thought they were lovely this
is not personal and I'm not taking any
personal pot shots at Joe Biden that's
not what this is about for me at all no
I was just curious because I also spent
time with uh him and and Jill unless I
was family members but they were also
always very warm and positive lovely
people
lovely people uh you know I I think
that's one of the
issues and it sounds like you and I have
a slightly different take on it but I
like like I think that Joe was the right
candidate for 2020
um but yeah well obviously he was yeah
he obviously
and all credit where credit is due yeah
but I also think you know that's not
that that's not necessarily true in 2024
personally well not only that I think
there's more than that as well for me
which is yes we didn't fall over the
cliff by electing Trump but we're still
six inches away from the cliff uh the
that's true
and I don't think that you know I I
think of the Biden agenda you know
particularly if if the Biden
Administration plans to come at the the
2024 elections uh with a message to the
American people that the economy is
doing well the unbelievable disconnect
between whatever Geniuses and whatever
DC think tanks will come up with a
message like that versus the visceral
experience of the majority of Americans
64 percent of whom are living paycheck
to paycheck just shows the that you know
Washington it I've always heard it was a
bubble it's more than a bubble it's a
walled off City it's a you you don't
know what's going on in this country if
you're going to go submit to the
American people that the economy is
doing well which by the way means that
you learn nothing from 2016. so what I
see in in Joe Biden is the effort to
help people
survive a basically unjust economic
system the what I wish to submit to the
American people is that this
Administration will end the unjust
system it's not enough to just help
people survive we should the government
should be helping people thrive and that
would mean more than shaving off a
little College loan here getting a
little bit more to Obamacare over there
it would mean Universal Health Care it
would mean free College
tuition-free college and and tech school
it would mean free child care it would
mean Paid Family Leave it would mean a
guaranteed livable wage it's business if
we're going to take these incremental
approaches and give you a little bit
here a little bit there it still amounts
of the Republicans offering you crumbs
the Democrats offering you a cookie and
I think every American should be able to
Feast on the rights and the
opportunities economic and otherwise
that are afforded by the richest country
in the world that's a vision of
abundance that at the vision of
abundance and we have abundance that's
the thing we have abundance the issue is
who has the abundance so over the last
48 years as I'm sure you're aware we
have had a massive transfer of wealth
which is really a nice way of putting
institutional theft a 50 trillion
dollars that have gone from the bottom
ninety percent of Americans are the top
one percent we have plenty of wealth in
this country it's who holds it it's held
by very few people and we have policy
after policy both in terms of our tax
structures in terms of our corporate
subsidies
that actually make it easier for those
who already have to get more and makes
it harder for the average American to
even make it when you have 60 of
Americans who couldn't even absorb a 400
unexpected expenditure 500 000 people
falling into medical debt every year
half of our seniors living on twenty
five thousand dollars a year and less
and on and on and on the people in this
country are in trouble and the way to
win in 2024 is not for the Democrats to
say hey things are doing well economy is
getting better because people people
know what they know in their gut and
they do vote with their feelings and you
can't blame them for that it makes sense
to do that we are the wealthiest country
in the history of the world and we
should be able to do a lot better uh by
our people than we're doing right now so
you reference DC as a Walled Garden uh
and you've been spending more time in DC
over the last few years uh what what uh
have you gotten out of that uh because
I've never lived in DC I'm curious what
your experience has been well people
people are the same everywhere and
there's some wonderful people here but
it's also interestingly Ground Zero
isn't it for some of the people you have
three times the amount of corporate
lobbyists that you have legislators in
this town so some of the people
legislators
so
some of the forces that are making what
you and I would consider the most
nefarious plans for how Healthcare
should operate in this country how food
should operate in this country how
energy should operate in this country
how foreign policy should operate in
this country some of the people who
represent obesis to the bottom line of
corporate profit maximization for huge
corporate entities even at the expense
of the workers at the expense of Health
well-being and Safety and Security of
people animal and planets they are
headquartered here
but also headquartered here are people
who are
doing their darndest to try to make it
better some of whom are the brave
exceptions to the corporatist uh Bunch
which runs the government but also ngos
staff members so you meet both here it's
kind of ground zero and also I think you
said something before Andrew that I
think is important for us to note you
said given that we are the richest
country in the world we should be able
to do better no we can do better they
choose not to do better remember when
you're talking about things like
Universal Health Care livable wage paid
family leave these things are considered
moderate positions
in most advanced democracies so we have
one group of people here who just don't
care about that and the other group of
people who say it's complicated Andrew
it's not complicated it's corrupt
so if you have you know if you have a
some leaders basically within the
Republican Party who just don't care to
solve all that gargantuan sea of
economic despair out there but then you
have others who don't have the spine to
fix it who don't have the moral courage
to fix it we need to get in there people
who are not part of that system and say
that we will
that's why I'm a